he lands
serve the lord with gladness come before
his presence with singing
know ye thou the lord he is god
it is he that hath made us and not we
ourselves
we are his people and the sheep of his
pasture
enter into his gates with thanksgiving
and into his courts with praise
be thankful unto him and bless his name
for the lord is good
his mercy is everlasting and his truth
endureth to all generations
god is good and all the time
good evening everyone how was your day
it was good well we thank god for that
every day around the world people die
am i right yes they die
you and i are alive by the grace of god
let us thank god for life one of my
favorite bible passages
is a psalm 34 verses 1-3
i will bless the lord at all times
his praise shall continually be in my
mouth
my soul shall make her boast in the lord
the humble shall hear thereof and be
glad
o magnify the lord with me and let us
exalt his name together and so i say
again god is good
come on that's weak god is good and
all the time who is with us tonight you
are not a seventh-day adventist
you are here for the first time with
your hand
first time ah oh how nice
would you kindly stand all those who
raise their hands
please stand we want to recognize you
here's the microphone for you to your
left
good evening hello good evening to
everyone how are you
i'm fine what's your name i'm betty
say it again betty betty yes
where are you from berry from kabuya
laguna i am invited
mom felma a sister of sister agnes
sister agnes invited you yes thank you
very much for coming
thank you we're delighted you're here
may the lord bless you in all that you
do
say amen for our friend you may be
seated my lovely sister
okay thank you all right someone else
i saw a few hands when i said stand up
the hands came down
who is the next person i saw hands over
there
[Music]
please stand and tell us your name
oh he is oh he's not a visitor all right
i saw a hand today
you're not a seventh-day adventist you
are with us for the first time
raise your hand first side
and there's someone to my left let's get
the microphone to her
right over here
all right a microphone is coming
pass that down good evening
good evening how are you i'm good what
are you laughing at
it's nice to see you what's your name
i'm love love yeah oh what a lovely name
love ah that's a nice name
god is love first john 4 8 first john 4
16.
who invited you ah aup friendly
a lot of people yes well sister love
thanks for coming i really mean that
we're delighted you've come and your
laughter increases the light in this
room
may the lord bless you and bless your
families amen for love
you can't have too much love your
husband will be a lucky man
he's married to love all right is there
anybody else you are not a seventh-day
adventist
where tell that handsome man to stand up
all right good evening uh good evening
sir
how are you i'm good what's your name
jay agustin
who jay augustine
jay yeah jay where are you from uh
silent cavite that's uh okay silent
cavity all right and who invited you
the castro family oh that they're my
family too yeah
brother jay thank you for coming you're
welcome sir you're wearing a white shirt
white represents the righteousness of
jesus christ god bless you
and we'll be here all week try to come
again say amen
for jay i did not ask sister love just
the love where are you from we have
another one she's shy
where are you from sister love where
where are you from originally
where pampanga liberia all right
all right god bless liberia okay anybody
else
uh sister ami asked her to stab
yes good evening hi how are you
good nice to see you are you nice to see
me say yes
yes good all right
where are you from what's your name ami
who
ami ami ami
yes amy amy where are you from
all right tell us who invited you
[Music]
and drip oh okay very good emily thank
you very much for coming
may god grant you all the desires of
your heart say email
say it again god is good
and all the time how many of you love
god can i see your hand you love god
this is no joke you love god
thank you god bless you god is happy are
there any other guests
where okay we're on this side now we've
got to come back to that side
all right let's find out who they are
ask them to stand please
please stand
good evening how are you i'm
we're good nice to see you why is this
lovely lady sitting
uh my wife your wife is a lovely lady
what's her name
mary can we hear her voice my name is
mary
mary is a good name the mother of jesus
where are you from mary magdalene
yeah yeah but but
but i prefer mary the mother of jesus
and my surname is ayden okay now where
are you from
we're from santa rosa santo rosa yes
okay and who invited you pastor joel
pastor joel is my brother we've worked
together for many years he's a good man
you're blessed to have him as a leader
say amen for our friends
say it again god is good
and all the time yes god
i like god i love him and i like him
okay anybody else
ask her to stand up
i will translate okay all right tell i
said hello
hi hi now ah there we are
oh she sat back down what's her name
giuseppe goes to feign oh that's a nice
name where are you from josephine
who invited you tonight dr de castro
oh that's my brother thank you very much
for coming salamat paul
may the lord bless your life say amen
for our sister
god bless you you may be seated anybody
else
you finally decided you're a visitor all
right
hold on a minute we want to make sure
you get full attention
oh there's somebody else hold on hold on
hold on good evening good evening good
evening how are you
fine what's your name
say it again lucina
yeah where are you from lucina city
where hey
who invited you dr dicastro dr castro is
a good man
thank you very much for coming god bless
you god bless you
say amen all right we're over here
god bless all our guests
good evening my dear sister good evening
how are you i'm fine how are you
i'm fine thanks for asking what's your
name
i'm a pallet reader say it slowly a
pallet
reader who oh
all right that's more merciful rita all
right where are you from rita
i'm from aap from where you p
originally the country yeah who
uganda oh mukam
ah god bless you
ah that's that's one of my home
countries uganda who invited you
to my friend who is bahati she's here
god bless you my dear god bless you i
mean that from my heart
say amen god bless uganda i go there
very often i have beautiful friends
in the pearl of africa as uganda used to
be called oh it's still called
anyone else
right here you're not a visitor
[Music]
ask her her name hello
where she's from
and who invited here
she is invited by jesus christ okay
all right say amen
[Music]
god bless you god bless you god bless
you all right
god is good and all the time
it is seven minutes after seven i want
to release you before 8 o'clock
all right time to be silent quiet we're
worshiping god
i'm very happy to see you my friends on
the outside
i'm happy to see you i'm so sorry we
don't have the room for you but we're
all one
despite the walls our subject for this
evening
suffering in silence what did i say
as usual if you're using a phone
please make sure it does not ring now
since we're in the house of god
please don't go surfing on your phones
during the service
don't do that it's respectful to god
favor number two while i'm speaking pray
for me and say
lord put your words in that man's mouth
and favor number three i want you to
think
as you listen think
as you listen all right
let's pray
our father in heaven thank you for life
thank you today god for freedom of
worship
we thank you father we arrive safely no
accidents
no harm no danger
i present myself to you today god to be
used by you
if i have sinned against you forgive me
father
that's why jesus christ died cleanse me
use me regard as you see fit i offer no
resistance
put your words in my mouth father put
thoughts in my head
and help me to speak with humility and
with the attitude of jesus christ
bless all those who have come a very
special blessing on all our guests there
god
double the blessing upon them father i
pray for this country of the philippines
i pray for the leaders particularly the
president give all of them
wisdom from above that they may guide
this nation in the right direction
and the right direction is always an
upward direction
bless every other nation represented by
this audience father
at the end of this message let every man
woman boy and girl
know that he or she has heard from you
not from me in jesus name i pray
let god's people say amen and
amen genesis chapter 1
reading from verse 1
oh very good ah god bless you god bless
you
say it with me now in the beginning god
created
the heaven and the earth now i have a
question for you
for this side tell me something god
created
on the earth
people very good something else
on the earth animals
something else
trees something else water
something else okay someone said animals
the repetition is good
someone said fresh air something else
grass something else
no on the earth there are no stars on
the earth on the earth
birds and fish one more on the earth
flowers all right now on what day was
adam made
the sixth day is the last day now
when adam opened his eyes what did he
see
remember what he just told me what did
adam see
okay okay it's all light what else did
he saw fruit trees what did the fruit
trees provide
food he saw fresh clean
unpolluted water he saw
animals with which to fellowship they
did not eat people
he saw grass
he saw fish in the water he saw
birds in the air he breathed fresh
invigorating air now what that tells us
about god
is this god provided
everything adam needed then made adam
and god hasn't changed question for you
could god have made adam on the first
day
yes but the world was not yet ready for
adam
god could have made him on the second
day god made adam
after everything he needed
had been provided that's the way god is
going to john chapter 6
john chapter 6.
ah we'll read from verse 1. john chapter
reading from verse 1 what's our subject
quickly
suffering in silence do you have john
chapter 6
john is my second favorite book of the
bible what question should you ask me
what's your favorite book it's genesis
all right john 6
reading from verse 1 how many of you
have the king james version match your
hands
all right read with me what does that
say
after these things jesus went over the
sea
galilee which is the
and a great multitude followed him
because they saw his miracles
which he did on them that were deceased
and jesus went up into a mountain
and there he sat with his disciples and
the passover
a feast of the jews was nigh carefully
now
when jesus then lifted up his eyes and
saw a great company come unto him
he saith unto philip tell me what he
said
when shall we by bread that these may
eat stop christ was in the wilderness
five thousand men came to hear him plus
women
and children he preached all day it's
coming to the end of the day
they are hungry there are no stores no
supermarket
they are in the wilderness and so jesus
said to philip
where will we buy bread to feed these
people
read verse six carefully
nice and loud come on i'm listening
and this he said to prove him come on
for he himself knew what he would do
stop
what does that tell you about god
listen again five thousand men
plus women and children no food
in sight the bible says
jesus already knew what he would do
but he still asked phillip how shall we
see them
because even though god knows what he
will do in your life
he has to test you let me say it again
someone listening to me has a problem
that needs solution
god has the solution he already knows
how he'll get you out of it but he has
to test you
and so jesus said to philip when shall
we buy bread
that these may eat verse 6 says and this
he said
to prove him for he himself
knew what he would do let me repeat
god has the solution to the problems
you're facing
but he has to test you
let's learn something else about god we
found out from genesis
god provides and then brings us to all
that he provided
we found out in john god always has an
answer
but he has to test us let us go to psalm
37 our subject
suffering in silence psalm
37 we'll read verse 4.
i'm very pleased to see some of you
writing these verses down
that's excellent very excellent of you
to do that
psalm 37 verse 4
do you have that if you have my version
read with me
what does it say delight thyself
also in the lord and he will
give thee the desires of thy heart
let me tell you a story very short i was
in south africa preaching about four
five years ago
and a young lady spoke to me she said
pastor i would love to visit your
country of the united states
but it is so hard to get a visa
and i said to her who has more power
the embassy of god
where she said god i said are you a
child of god
she said yes i said ask god
for a visa now please him in your life
because god is not a supermarket please
god
and ask him for a visa
tell him father this is your world i'd
like to visit
a part of your world called the united
states of america
please give me a visa six weeks later
she sent me an email she said i got
a visa what does psalm 37
say delight thyself also in the lord
finish the verse and he will
give you what the desires of your heart
go to psalm 84.
psalm 84
he's 20 after seven
you have psalm 84
nobody answered the preacher all right
okay let's pray again holy father in
heaven
i do not want to speak long without
seeking more grace
give it to me give me the power that i
may present clearly
in jesus name i pray amen psalm 84
11 read that with me what does that say
for the lord
is a sun and a shield come on the lord
will give
and carefully now finish the verse
no good thing will we withhold from them
that walk out
uprightly stop
no good thing
the bible says he that findeth a wife
findeth a good thing
and psalm says no good thing we live
with whole so you gentlemen looking for
wives
ask god he'll give you one
you ladies looking for husbands ask god
he'll give you the right one one that
will never leave you
one i will never leave the church one
who will never make you a punch in bag
ask god no good thing
will he withhold from them that walk
uprightly
question for you now this side what did
we learn from genesis 1
you're taking too long
god provides everything we need and
brings us to the situation
what did we learn from john 6
god always has a solution to our
problems
anyone now what did we learn from
psalm 37 4. he will give you
come on the desires of your heart what
did we learn from psalm 84 11
no good thing now it has to be good
will he withhold from them that walk
uprightly
go to jeremiah 29 we're learning about
god
and jesus is the same way so is the holy
ghost
jeremiah 29 we'll read a very well-known
verse
verse 11.
all right someone up front found it very
quickly
anybody else you have jeremiah 29
verse 11 read with me what does that say
for i know the thoughts i think the word
you said the lord
thoughts of peace not of evil stop
god does not think evil of anybody
he does not i know the thoughts
i think the word you said the lord
thoughts of peace
not of evil finish the verse to give you
an expected end or a blessed future
god always thinks good thoughts about
you
okay having put all these things
together
let's go to mark chapter 10.
we read from verse 46 mark 10
reading from verse 46.
no don't read that yet go to matthew 7.
almost of that matthew 7 we'll get back
to mark in a minute
matthew 7 we'll read verse 11.
and all parents read this verse
carefully
if you have children read this verse
carefully all
parents and do you have matthew 7
verse 11 if you have my version read
with me what does the bible say
if he then being evil know
how to give good gifts unto your
children how much more
shall your father which is in heaven
give good things
to them that ask him stop
there's an interesting statement in that
verse jesus is speaking he says
if he then being evil know how to give
good gifts
god is saying even evil people they have
some ability to determine
what's a good gift
an atheistic parent can still determine
a good gift
for his or her child if he then being
evil says jesus
inside what's best for your children
what about god
who is good and so the verse tells us
god
knows how to give good things
to those who ask
now the verse says good things am i
right look at the verse
tell me if i'm right does the verse say
good things
how many good things we don't know
god is infinite now luke
says the same thing but he uses
slightly different words go to luke
11 let's read verse 13. luke 11
13 our subject suffering in silence
my young brother up front you're very
fast god bless you
luke 11 reading verse 13 do you have
that
my king james people read with me if he
then
being evil know how to give good gifts
unto your children
how much more shall your heavenly father
give the holy spirit
to them that now
in matthew 7 11 we have good things
in luke 11 13 we have the holy spirit
but luke and matthew are recording the
same
speech from jesus follow me closely
matthew says good things
what does luke do by saying the holy
spirit
hear all the good things god can give to
us
matthew just says good things
luke says the holy spirit what then is
luke saying about all the good things
the most important good thing god can
give to you
finish my words it's the holy spirit
say amen let me say it again the most
precious gift god can give to you
is the holy spirit because the holy
spirit is the manager of everything god
has
it is he that gives the gifts to the
church it is he that convicts of sin
it is he that makes the words of christ
comprehensible to us
see that gives the power to overcome sin
the holy spirit
is the most precious gift god can give
to you
now we've learned a lot about god
genesis
he provides first then he brings us
uh john he always has an answer but he
has to test us
psalm he gives us the desires of our
hearts
psalm he withholds no good thing from us
jeremiah he thinks only good thoughts
about us
matthew and look he knows how to give
good gifts if all of that is clear say
amen
now go to mark 10. from verse 46
it's 28 minutes after 7. i'll release
you before 8
please don't panic
what book did i say mark what chapter
10 reading from what first 46
when you found it sir man are you ready
to read
no not yet not yet not yet not yet let
me pray again
holy father please continue to be with
me i say it very sincerely
in jesus name amen read with me
and they came to jericho and as
he went out of jericho with his
disciples
and a great number of people blind
bartimaeus
the son of timaeus sat by the highway
side
begged freely and when he heard
it was jesus he began to cry out and say
jesus thou son of have
mercy on me what did he mean by
have mercy on me heal me
what was his problem he was blind
have mercy on me next verse
and many charge him that he should do
what
hold this peace but he cried for more a
great deal
thou son of david have mercy on me
let me tell you a secret about god a cry
for mercy
is always answered by god
a genuine cry for mercy the bible says
who is a god like unto thee that pardon
this iniquity and passeth by the
transgression
of the remnant of his heritage he
retaineth
not his anger forever because he
delighteth finish the verse in mercy
god loves to be merciful and so
bartimaeus said
have mercy on me verse 49
read with me and jesus stood
still and commanded him to be called
and they called the blind man saying
unto him be of good comfort
rise he calleth thee and he
casting away his garment rose and came
to jesus stop
leading chapel with his disciples and a
large group
following him bartimaeus heard it was
christ
he knew this might be his only chance he
cried
have mercy jesus kept walking
he cried again let me tell you something
about god
there are some people who believe why
should i pray to god he already knows
what i want
jesus prayed to god hebrews 5
verse 7 and 8 tells us he prayed with
tears
and crying one of the reasons our
prayers
are not answered we don't keep crying
out to god
and so god assumes we're not serious
when you pray
cry out to god and cry out to god
until like jesus in verse 49
he stands still
and he came to jesus 51 read with me
and jesus answered and said to him what
with thou
that i should do unto thee
that's an old english expression what
without that i
should do unto thee i want you to put
that in modern
new valley english how would you say
what do you want what do you want
question for you if god came to you
tonight
and said to you what do you want
what would you say let me go and pray
about it
if god came to you and said what do you
want
when bartimaeus cry to god jesus
who created heaven and earth and
everything in the universe
he stopped he said bring that man the
man came jesus looked at him and said
what do you want you're calling me
the blind man said unto him lord
that i might receive my sight
and immediately you receive the sight
and follow jesus in the way
you know jesus told him go thy way thy
faith had made the whole
he's received his sight immediately now
some people they never tell god what
they want
and so they what's our subject
suffer in silence
they don't tell god
there's a woman she's been married 10
years
she's dying to have a child
tell god
there's someone the doctor gave you bad
news
and you're dying inside from fear
tell god
you've got three children your husband
passed away or left you
you don't know how you'll feed them
tell god
you have a young boy he's 16.
he's moving with the wrong friends and
he's this far from getting into drugs
and alcohol
you have a wife or a husband
who seems to be unfaithful
oh god you're at aup
tuition must be paid tomorrow
it's a christian school but it needs
money
tell god do not
come on do not suffer in silence
god is the god who likes talking how did
he make
the light what did he say let there be
light god loves to talk
how many times did he write commandments
once how many times did he speak well
he wrote them twice spoke them once but
for every day of creation
he spoke he spoke speak to god tell him
and jesus answered and said unto him
what will thou
that i should what do you want that's
what we call
perhaps you call it the same thing in
the philippines a blank check
you know what a blank check is it's a
check
signed by the person with the money with
your name on it
but not the amount you fill in the
amount
if president rodrigo duterte gave you a
blank check with his signature
written on the basis of the financial
strength of the bank of the philippines
and he told you fill in the amount would
you fill in 200 pesos
that's not faith the fact that he would
give you a blind check says
he thinks a lot about you god gave
that blind man a blank check
and told him fill it in and he filled it
in
that i might see
i have a question for you tonight
god is asking you what do you want
go to uh nehemiah chapter 2.
nehemiah chapter two we'll read from
first one
you may have a little difficulty finding
nehemiah
find psalms and work your way backward
you run into job then esther then
nehemiah
do you have nehemiah chapter two
we'll read from verse one and i ask my
heavenly father again to put his words
in my mouth
do you have nehemiah two verse one king
james
people read with me what does it say and
it came to pass
in the month nissan in the 20th year of
artaxerxes the king
that wine was before him and i took up
the wine
and gave it unto the king now i had not
been before time said
in his presence now stop let me explain
something nehemiah
had a very unusual job now some of your
teachers
some of you may be doctors some of you
lawyers some of you whatever
you run your little shop your little
business needy maya's work listen to me
carefully
he worked for the king his job was
taste the wine before the king drank it
just in case the wine was poisoned
that was his work it was very very
important work so he could not come into
the presence of the king
looking sad the king may assume
that something is wrong with the wine
and so nehemiah says
now i had not been before time sat
in his presence wherefore the king said
unto me
why is thy countenance sad this is
nothing else but sorrow of heart
then i was very so afraid read with me
first three
and said unto the king let the king live
forever
why should not my countenance be sad
when the city
the place of my father's sepulchers
lieth waste and the gates thereof are
consumed with fire nehemiah said to the
king king
i heard that my the city of my father's
nehemiah was born in captivity he was
not born in jerusalem
so he just heard the condition of
jerusalem he said i am
sad it's like you're living in the
united states and you heard an
earthquake destroyed manila
then like an earthquake damaged the fowl
your heart would be so
sad nehemiah heard
verse 4 read verse 4 for me
then the king said unto me what
no it's okay it's okay it's okay it's
okay
for what does thou make request
that sounds like what without that i
shall do unto thee
but for what does thou make requests in
new valley english
what do you want now we have two kings
asking two human beings
what you want is jesus king of kings
tell me quickly
yes was he god he was man
yes here is god asking the blind man
what do you want
here is the biggest king on earth back
then asking nehemiah
what do you want do you know the king
gave him more than he asked for
28.
i have a question for you i want you to
believe tonight
that jesus who is the same yesterday
today and forever is asking you
right now what do you want
this is no joke let's pray father as i
proceed in the final minutes
let your spirit move upon every heart i
pray
in jesus name amen now think
i am speaking for christ i am going to
ask you what he asked the blind man
someone on this side what do you want
jesus to do for you
i want you to tell me raise your hand
and tell me i'll let you think i'll come
back to you
someone on this side raise your hand
tell me
i'll come back i'll okay yes
you want jesus to help your children
finish their studies
very good the bible says jesus increased
in wisdom and stature
thank you i'm asking for serious
requests
god is asking you what will thou
that i shall do unto thee or like king
arthur xerxes
what do you want someone on this side
and then we'll pray yes my sister
i want to finish my studies in four
years
you want to finish your studies in four
years all right that's what you're
telling jesus thank you
someone else yes
i want god to give me a wisdom
as a virtuous woman of powers 31
10 to 30. yes yeah
yes god bless you
someone else raise your hand
jesus is asking you what do you want
is there someone outside with a raised
hand
get them what do you want
then we'll pray and present those
requests to god
someone else what do you want
yes here's a brother right here
i want a heart and a character like
christ ourselves you want the
character of christ
you just put a smile on the face of god
somebody else
what do you want tell him
someone else yes
right over here right over here right
over here then we'll come back to where
you were going
yes my dear sister i want god to direct
the purpose of my life you want god to
direct her
the purpose of your life yes you know
elohim says a distinct
work is given to every christian he has
a purpose for you
no one is alive who does not have a
purpose yes sister
i have so many uh to tell one but
uh as for now i want god to heal my mom
because
you want god to heal your mother yes all
right thank you nothing for yourself
for somebody else sounds like solomon
praying to god
yes
all right i'll say you tell me
you want god to teach you how to be an
obedient daughter
commandment number uh ephesians 6 1
children
obey your appearance in the lord for
this israel god bless you your parents
will be happy
jesus luke 2 51 jesus went down to
nazareth
and was subject to his parents he obeyed
them
and he was god somebody else
yes my good brother right up front
remember christ is asking you right now
what with thou
that i shall do unto thee i want god's
will to be fulfilled in my life
you want god god's will what's will to
be fulfilled in your life
somebody else yeah we're in the back to
my left your right
quarter to eight
i want god to help me set up the
wellness center in palawan so to serve
more people cerebral wellness center in
palawan you said
all right somebody else what do you want
god to do for you
he's asking you tonight yes
yes i want god to heal me you want god
to heal you
okay psalm 103 verse
3 who forgiveth all that iniquities who
healeth all thy diseases
exodus 15 26 for i am the lord that
healeth me
anybody else what do you want god to do
for you
keep looking outside there may be
someone outside raise
hand where is this person ah
all right the question is from jesus
what do you want
i want god to heal me and
to help my children to behave you want
god to heal you
and to help your children to behave
[Music]
somebody else right up front
i'm being very serious by the way this
is very serious
god is listening yes he wants
one family whole family is believed
jesus
you want whole family
it's one one religion oh
yes okay the whole family following
christ
yes thank you very much anybody else
anyone outside over here yes my dear
sister what do you want god to do for
you
i want lord that helped my family to be
one and especially i hope he will
heal all my sickness okay you want your
life to be one in christ
and you want physical healing okay
[Music]
somebody else yes sister
and i want to give protect
for maintenance earthquake
earthquake or protection from earthquake
okay the bible says there'll be
earthquakes all over the world
but the bible also says that god is a
safety he's a hiding place he's a place
of
for his people all right yes my young
brother
i want god to bless the valley church
amen amen god loves the blessed church
yes in the back bless the new valley
worship center
a worship congregation i believe it is
yes
god really amends to his people
in this area you want god to do what a
man
immense pastor amends these people in
the area
you want god to do what to amend amen
in the area a men's like maybe a broken
relationship oh men oh yes yes yes all
right thank you thank you thank you
thank you
salamat anybody else and then we'll pray
and present these to god right now
somebody else i want god
that our friend and adventist with us
tonight will accept jesus as their
savior
yes yes they're all right that person is
here tonight
to accept christ beautiful prayer
somebody else yes we're over here
then we'll pray it's a quarter to eight
and i promise to release you before
eight
and i tend to keep that word
yes sister okay i just want god to
protect
like my family and me here protect your
family
and you yes
[Music]
no weapon formed against you will
prosper anybody else
yes my young brother yes yes right there
right there
yes he wants god to do something for you
tell jesus he's listening
he never sleeps
then they want many kids to obey yes
you want children to obey amen amen
one of the most beautiful things on
earth is an obedient child
anybody else anybody else
yes i want to tell jesus to help my
husband
you want jesus to help your husband yes
you do what sick
he's sick okay okay okay okay okay
anybody else yes
tell us again i'm sorry we should have
had two mites
you don't have to be running around okay
uh i forget to say okay ask for
wisdom wisdom for finishing in four
years i
really need wisdom yes my god okay james
5 if any of you lack wisdom let him ask
of god
that giveth to all men liberally of
course wisdom is rooted
in the word of god yes right over here
right over here we have a brother
and sister love it looks like okay
yes my good brother god is good yes
and all the time
my name is victor yes and i'm from aop
uh-huh my brother he invited me
okay and it's been a blessing so
if it's possible i would like
that god could provide anyone who could
speak
the word of god every day to me because
whenever i'm done whenever i'm
weak when i listen to the word of god
i'm
still okay strong yes yes yes
all right very good if you can't find
anyone my brother
the word is right here god will speak
you through the word even if you can't
find
a human agent he'll talk to you directly
yes my dear sister
right there all right here we go
here's the mic
oh yes i want god to
provide for my parents yes so they can
be able to pay my fees with
four years okay and then i want guy to
help me
to be i want guy to heal my uncle is
sick
okay then yes we all have many
and it's okay it's okay and then i want
guy to
help me with more wisdom okay and
understanding
to proceed through my education amen
amen
financial help yes again chapter 2 verse
8 the silver is mine
and the gold is mine saith the lord all
right i'll take another then we'll pray
yes what do you want god to do for you
i hope and pray that i want god to help
me as i continue
a literature evangelist you owe you an
illicit evangelist
very important work god bless you god
bless you all right
oh there's another okay and there's one
in the back
um i want my brother to be healed
you want your brother to be healed okay
sister and my
friend say it again your brother to be
healed
and her friend and her friend all right
god heard you
there's someone we're in the back all
right another right here first
i pray and want that god will
to take good care of my kids my family
and to be used as an instrument
to further the message of god okay
very good very good all right we're in
the back up against the wall we're in
the back
and then we'll pray
i pray to god that he could grant me a
wisdom
his wisdom so that i could help more
people
amen amen jesus himself is wisdom all
right
we are going to stand we are saying
of one verse after god be the glory
great things he's done
then we'll pray let's all stand
i'm sure you know the first verse a
minute up in the stream to god be the
glory great things he's done
to god be the glory
great things
so lovely the world that
he gave us is
[Music]
that all may go away
praise the
the lord let the earth is
his voice praise the lord praise the
lord
let the people rejoice
[Music]
through jesus
now very quietly i want you to kneel
wherever you can if you have a physical
problem it's okay you don't have to
but if you can it doesn't cause pain
kneel with me
our father in heaven we come
on bended knee in your holy presence
dear god
we confess we admit we deserve
nothing from you the father we let you
down so often dear god
we sin so frequently father but you are
long suffering you're patient
you're not willing that any should
perish
father as we kneel i think of the words
in matthew 11
spoken by jesus christ himself verse 28
come unto me all ye that labor
and are heavy laden and i will give you
rest i think of the words in matthew 7
ask and he shall receive knock
and the door shall be opened unto you
seek and he shall find father
we come knocking tonight we come
seeking tonight we come asking tonight
because you've invited us to come
first we ask you forgive us their god
wherever we have sinned against you
father forgive us their god
with that forgiveness pour into our
hearts to overflowing
a hatred for sin and a love for doing
what is right
father you've heard all the requests
that were mentioned
jesus said to that blind man what do you
want
he is the same yesterday today and
forever and
from his place in heaven he has said to
us
what do you want and father we have
responded
some of us want health we want financial
assistance
we want families united we want our
friends saved
we want to wishing we want wisdom
we want guidance we want protection
father a list of requests were brought
to you
because the question to the blind man is
for
us today what do you want
some of us want your will fulfilled in
our lives
there god in the name of jesus
christ who asked the blind man that
question look upon us dear god
with mercy look upon us with favor
and from the goodness of your heart
begin to
answer these requests father
answer so generously that we will
know that only god can bless this way
father draw us close to your bosom dear
god
and keep us there wrap us in your arms
father
because your bosom is the safest place
we
thank you for the generosity of the
question
what do you want we've told you
father help us to tell you every day
until
our prayers are answered thank you for
the bible
thank you for truth thank you for safe
worship tonight
as we journey home dear god take us
safely
let us leave with the confidence our
loving father has heard
and he will do what is best for us we
offer this prayer
in jesus name let god's people say amen
and amen